in general i have this disagreement with
my dad
about what it takes to have a connection
he thinks touch and smell are really
important
like um and i
i still believe that text alone
is it's possible to fall in love with
somebody just with text
but visual can also help just like with
the avatar and so on what do you think
it
takes does uh does a chatbot i need to
have a face
voice or can you really form a deep
connection with text alone
i think text is enough for sure a
question is like can you
you know make it better if you have
other if you include other things as
well and i think you know we all
will talk about her um
but her you know had carol johansson
voice which was perfectly
um you know perfect intonation perfect
pronunciations
and you know she was breathing heavily
in between words and
whispering things you know nothing like
that is possible right now with um
text of speech generation you'll you'll
have these flat
news anchor type voices and maybe some
emotional voices but
um you'll hardly understand some of the
words
um some of the words will be muffled so
that's like the current
state state of the art so you can't
really do that but if we had
scarlet carol johansen voice and all of
these capabilities
then of course voice would be totally
enough or even text would be totally
enough if we had you know a little more
memory um and slightly better
conversations
i would still argue that even right now
we could have just kept the text only we
still had tons of people in long-term
relationships and
really invested in their um ai friends
but we thought that why not you know why
why do we need to keep playing with our
you know
hands tied behind us we can
easily just you know add all these other
things that is pretty much a solved
problem you know we can add 3d graphics
we can put this
uh these avatars in augmented reality
and all of a sudden there's
there's more and maybe you can't feel
the touch
but you can you know with uh body
occlusion and with
uh current ar uh
and you know on the iphone on you know
the next one there's going to be a
lidars
you can touch it and it will you know it
will pull away
or will blush or something or it's a
smile
so you can't touch it you can't feel it
but you can see the reaction to that
so in a certain way you can even touch
it a little bit and maybe you can even
dance with it or do something else um
so i think why limiting ourselves if we
can use all of these
technologies that are much easier in a
way than than conversation well it
certainly could be richer but
to play devil's advocate i mentioned you
uh offline that
i was surprised in having tried discord
and having voice conversations with
people how intimate
voices alone without visual like to me
at least
like it was an order of magnitude
greater degree of intimacy in voice i
think than with video
i don't because people were more real
with voice
like with video you like try to present
a shallow
uh a face to the world like you try to
you know make sure you're not wearing
sweatpants or whatever
but like with voice i think people were
just
more faster to get to like the core of
themselves
so i don't know it was surprising to me
uh they've
they've even had a discord added a video
feature and like nobody was using it
uh there's a temptation to use it at
first but like
it wasn't the same so like that's an
example of something where
less was doing more and so that's uh
i guess that's the q that's the question
of uh
what is the optimal you know
what is the optimal medium of
communication to form a connection
given the current sets of the
technologies
i mean it's nice because they advertise
you have a replica like
it immediately like even the one
um i have is like
it's already memorable that's how i
think like when i think about
the replica that i've talked with that's
why i think
like that's what i visualize in my head
it became a little bit more real because
there's a visual component
but at the same time the you know what
do you do with
just what do i do with that knowledge um
that uh voice was so much more intimate
well the way i think about it is um
and by the way we're swapping out the 3d
finally it's going to look a lot better
but can you what we just don't i
hate how it looks right now we really
change it at all we're swapping it all
out
to a completely new look like the visual
look of the
of the reference and stuff we just had
it was just a super early mvp and
then we had to move everything to unity
and redo everything but
anyway i hate how it looks like now i
can't even like open it
but anyway um because i'm already in my
developer version i
hate everything that i see in production
i can't wait for it
why does it take so long that's why i
cannot wait for deployment to finally
take over all these
stupid 3d animations and 3d pipeline
also the 3d thing
when you say 3d pipeline is like how to
animate a face kind of thing
how to make this model how many bones to
put in the face
how many it's just and a lot of that is
by hand
oh my gosh everything by hand and if
there's no any
nothing's automated it's all completely
nothing like
just it's it's literally what you know
what we saw with chad boss in like 2012
do you think it's going to be possible
to learn a lot of that
of course i mean even now some deep
learning um
based animations and for the full body
for a face
we're talking about like the actual act
of animation or how to
create a compelling facial or body
language
thing sorry back too well that's the
next step okay
at least now something that you don't
have to do by hand gotcha
how uh good of a quality it will be like
can i just show it a photo and it will
make me a 3d model and then it will just
animate it
i'll show it a few animations of a
person i will just
start doing that but anyway go
go back to what's intimate and what to
use and whether less is more not
um my main goal is to
well the idea was how do i how do we not
keep people
in their phones so they're sort of
escaping reality
in this text conversation how do we
through this still bring bring it bring
our users back to reality
make them see their life in a different
la uh through a different lens
how can we create a little bit of
magical realism realism in their lives
so that through augmented reality
um by you know summoning your avatar
even if it looks
kind of danky not great in the beginning
or very
simplistic but summoning it to your um
living room and then the avatar looks
around and talks to you about
where it is and maybe turns your floor
into a dance floor and you guys dance
together
that makes you see reality in a
different light what kind of dancing are
we talking about like
like slow dancing whatever you want
i mean you would like slow dancing i
think that other people maybe want more
something more energy
what do you mean i would like so what is
this because you started with slow dance
so i just assumed that you're interested
in slow dancing all right what kind of
dancing do you like what
was your avatar what would you do it's
bad with dancing but
uh i like this kind of hip-hop robot
dance i used to break dance with a kid
so i still want to um
pretend i'm a teenager and learn some of
those moves
and i also like that type of dance that
happens when there's like a
um in like music videos with
the background dancers are just doing
something
[Laughter]
awesome that type of dance is definitely
what i want to learn but i think it's
great because if you see this
friend in your life and you can
introduce it to your friends then there
is a
potential to actually make you feel more
connected with your friends
or with people you know or show you life
around you in a different light
and it takes you out of your phone even
although weirdly you have to look
at it through the phone but it makes you
notice things around it and it can point
things out for you
and um so that is the main reason why i
wanted to have a physical
dimension um and it felt a little bit
easier than that kind of
bit strange combination uh in the movie
her when he has to show
samantha the world to the lens of his
phone but then at the same time talk to
her through
the phone headphone it just didn't seem
as potentially immersive so to say
so that's my main goal for augmented
realities like how do we
make your reality a little bit more
magic
you